[Music]
tristan is with us in davenport iowa hi
tristan how are you
uh better than
i should be
how about you better than i should be
what's up
uh well long story short i'm supposed to
be moving to the apartments up near the
moline western illinois university
facility
for engineering and uh well i'm not
going to have an income on there and
they want triple to
rent an income or a upfront payment fine
by me can't do a student loan so thank
goodness for that
and my family and i are having a little
dispute about this i'm thinking
a
gap year to save up as much money as i
can and
chunk it out like
would be
best in my head
and they're going
let's re
refinance the home and pay for it that
way
what would you recommend here
wow
uh a different apartment
i have to go to an apartment there's no
dorms up there and it's 100 miles from
the nearest campus no a different one
i have okay so western illinois
university has an engineering campus
and the engineering campus does not have
dorms i got that
but the apartment that you have
presented
has terms that you cannot do
so far
different apartment
there's one apartment in the entire town
no there's several and most of them have
the exact same no no no no no no no
nope
nope
you went to one
no i've called 10
i have records
okay
uh
i'm calling bull but anyway the um
well let's play it out so you didn't say
all of them okay how many how many how
many apartment complexes are in the
entire area you've done it enough i mean
there's a rich old lady with a garage a
rich old lady with a garage outback that
you could rent her garage
apartment for nothing and she'll work
with you and oh by the way you need to
work while you're in school i don't know
what this crap is you can't work
fair enough
and pay for the apartment i mean
it's just you all you do is cover the
rent living over a garage uh has got to
be way less than all the fancy
apartments with all the stuff there's a
way to do this
but you haven't exhausted all of your
options dave's ab absolutely right about
that and you have to exhaust all your
options
i i know you're right
i've only got
five weeks to figure it out though
you ain't got nothing else to do you
should be able to do this in 48 hours i
could rent it you could rent something
if you just get after it this thing
called the interweb you get out there on
that thing and you know thanks to al
gore you could find out a lot of
information or just you know hey if
listen if i paid you a hundred thousand
dollars to go solve this problem without
borrowing money
you could figure it out because you're a
sharp dude you're getting ready to go
into an engineer right
fair enough so here's the thing let me
tell you what here's what you're bumping
up against is two problems and i want to
help you with those because it's gonna
help you with a whole bunch of things
number one is if you will draw a line in
the sand in your life that says i don't
borrow money i have to figure out a way
to do this without borrowing money
suddenly other options will come out
because borrowing money is always the
easiest way to do almost anything
short term
but it destroys the long term
but i mean if you want if you want to
get a car it's easier to go borrow money
and walk off the lot with a car it's
harder than working and saving up money
to get a car if you want to
do anything fill in the blank borrowed
money is always the easiest upfront and
the hardest long term because you get to
pay back payments with interest and it
destroys and screws up your life and you
look back later and kick your own butt
because it didn't force you
to
seek out other creative alternatives to
the problem the second thing you don't
want to do
is you don't want to deal in absolutes
and fatalist thinking which is what
ken's pointing out and that that concept
is this when making decisions if the
only options on the table are dumb ones
you need more options not not start
rationalizing and declaring in your mind
well this is in
freaking nowhere near
nothing and there's only 10 apartments
and i called all 10 of them and so
that's it case closed i'm screwed and so
now i have to decide which stupid thing
i'm going to do of the two stupid
options and i will throw one other thing
to add to that list tristan this is
really important you've got family
that is recommending to you debt because
that's what everybody else does because
they think it's gonna pay off and they
think it's normal and i think there's
two things you're gonna have to realize
you have to do in this moment
you wanted us to tell you that you
shouldn't do debt and you know you
shouldn't do debt so you're going to
have to deal with
either disappointing your family or
resenting your family or finding a whole
different way of doing it and them not
understanding and that's okay that's
what i'm saying he has to disappoint
them well it's not like like he
no no what about the next door neighbor
no no no no no no no i'm talking about
the pressure he's feeling yeah he just
went and got an apartment that's all he
did yeah when family puts pressure on us
here's what we have to do we do what's
right and when what's right may
disappoint them and i don't mean
or confuse them yeah i'm just getting
the point i'm making is you will resent
them if you do something that you know
is wrong exactly and so i always want to
choose disappointing somebody
versus resenting them you know why i
think you've got them i think you're
obviously bright because you don't get
into engineering school if you're stupid
okay and um you know you've got an
incredibly bright future and a gap year
is not just not necessary
i mean figure out a way to find some
place to live get a get get somebody
else that's got an apartment already
that's a two bedroom and become their
roommate i don't know what it is but
this idea that you have to come up front
with money or take a gap year is the
only two possible options
um it's just not accurate tristan
it's just not accurate okay ken uh
that's two for two okay we gotta stop a
minute all right
so when i'm teaching leadership to entre
leaders people running businesses
i teach them the same situation it's
simple decision making framework okay
human beings
if we're not careful
um
we can
pick out something that we want to do
and we can't figure out a way to do the
thing
and that's both of these last two
callers um
we can't figure out a way to do the
thing that it's in front of us and and
so we box ourselves into a corner
without enough options when you're
making decisions when you're making
decisions
you need every possible option on the
table until a good one sticks its head
up
yeah
and when you're looking at things and
you're saying
i've got a bad idea or another bad idea
and i have to choose between the two bad
ideas
what's happening is is you have
you know you've convinced yourself that
you have to do one of them and you're
trying to figure out a way to justify oh
well it was the least of all evils
that's right and that's just not good
paradigm that's just not good critical
thinking skills so what it amounts to is
you've got to be another way there's got
to be another way there's got to be
another way there's got to be another
way and you just keep asking that
question until you figure out what that
other way is
and that's when you find the rich old
lady with the apartment with a garage
apartment out back and she thinks you're
a cute young college student and you
will clean her gutters for her that's
right and you will mow her grass and you
might end up with free rent and a new
friend
and you might end up with all kinds of
things you know increase quality
relationships in your life everything
else
versus um
i've got corporate
apartments over here so i hear this all
the time for instance with that's why
i'm calling bs on his apartment thing uh
because you know we've had different
empty personalities anthony o'neil when
he was here and others sit and call
apartment complexes and they said do you
have to have a fico score do you have to
have a fico score you have to have fico
score and nine out of 10 of them say no
but people tell me all the time you
can't run an apartment without a fico
score because they called to talk to the
one they wanted to rent right
and so then now i got to go get a credit
card because the one i wanted to rent
and so now you're coming i got two
stupid things yeah and one and they're
boxing me in
more options you need more options
here's the key you make the right
decision the big decision then you
manage
against that decision so i'm not going
to go into debt while i go to school i'm
not going to go in debt to live so
that's the decision now i go and i
manage against that decision that's the
key